this was news nobody in australia wanted
to wake up to
facebook blocking news feeds to its
users in response to a proposed
australian law that would make big tech
giants pay
for news feeds on their platforms prime
minister scott morrison immediately hit
back
saying australia would not be
intimidated in a statement he said
facebook's actions to unfriend australia
today
cutting off essential information
services on health and emergency
services
were as arrogant as they were
disappointing
i am in regular contact with the leaders
of other nations on these issues
and this was the reaction in parliament
this is outrageous
and unacceptable we expect that facebook
will fix these actions immediately and
never repeat them again
this is an assault on a sovereign nation
it is an assault
on people's freedom and in particular it
is an utter
abuse of big technologies market power
and control
over technology this will go around the
world
but this stops facebook and google have
fought the law
claiming it doesn't reflect how the
internet works and penalizes them
but facebook users were shocked that the
row had escalated like this
people will just revolt against it like
honestly
like especially the younger generation
there would just be
chaos if they banned facebook and google
i think facebook branding news is
terrible actually i do use facebook it
seems to be a catch-all
and i can get all of my news in the one
spot so it will really impact me
some media bosses fear the news vacuum
could now be filled with misinformation
the fact is at the moment some
probably a third of australians say that
they get their news from facebook
and without being able to have
fact-checked
quality information available to them
via the pages of many outlets like the
city morning herald
um we we believe it absolutely will lead
to misinformation
conspiracy theorists you know real
radicalism is set to thrive on their
platform
in recent days google has signed payment
deals with three major australian news
outlets
it remains to be seen how long facebook
and australia
stay unfriended and the brady sky news